en este vídeo vamos a definir esta
función
f x que es x por ea la menos 2 x
cuadrada así que esta función lo que lo
que queremos obtener de esta función son
sus valores críticos así que te invito a
que hagas una pausa y que pienses cuáles
son
ok entonces suponiendo que ya lo checas
te vamos a ver recordemos que es un
valor crítica en un crítico entonces se
es un valor crítico
un valor crítico y vamos realmente a
definir esto es un valor crítico de f
sí y sólo sí y aquí voy a poner esto que
es si con un doble y que significa sí
sólo si f prima de s es decir la
derivada evaluada en 60 o f prima en c
es indefinida está indefinido
ok entonces esta es nuestra definición
de valor crítico muy bien entonces para
esto vamos a utilizar la regla de la
cadena necesitamos por supuesto calcular
la derivada de f que es esto y que se ve
que hay que utilizar regla de la cadena
y regla del producto para encontrar
cuando la derivada se anula o cuando no
está definida muy bien entonces vamos a
calcular f prima de x va a ser igual a
la derivada con respecto de x de quien
pues vamos a utilizar ahora la regla del
producto sería la derivada de x y aquí
la derivada de x por la otra función que
es a la menos 2 x cuadrada y ahora hay
que sumar hay que sumar la derivada de
la segunda función que en nuestro caso
es la menos dos
x cuadrada esta derivada que multiplica
a la primera que es x muy bien entonces
esta primera es muy sencilla porque la
derivada de x con respecto de x
simplemente es una verdad entonces esto
no nos queda como esto será igual a ea
la menos 2 x cuadrada
y aquí hay que pensar como derivamos
estoy aquí usamos la regla de la cadena
la derivada de ea la menos 2x cuadrada
con respecto a menos 2 x cuadrada
es es que voy a ponerlo con rosa mejor
esto con rosa dije
vamos a ponerlo con rosa entonces esto
es a la menos dos x cuadrada por la
derivada de menos 2 x cuadrada respecto
de x y eso es
simplemente este pasa abajo
multiplicando y nos queda menos 4x y por
supuesto todavía hay que multiplicar por
la otra equis esta x de aquí muy bien
entonces esto ya se ve mucho más
amigable pero todavía podemos hacer más
porque podemos factorizar a la menos 2 x
cuadrada y a la menos 2 x cuadrada
multiplica
por un lado multiplica a 1 y por otro
lado a menos x voy a escribir esto con
verde esto de aquí es menos
aunque es menos 4x cuadrada esto fue
esta parte muy bien entonces esto ya es
nuestra derivada y tenemos que
preguntarnos cuando se anula o cuando no
está definido
ahora fijémonos que este primer factor
es a la menos dos x cuadrada está
definido para todos los números reales
muy bien esto está siempre definido y
esta parte de aquí también siempre está
definido entonces no puede ser un punto
crítico del tipo de aquel donde la
derivada no está definida entonces si
hay un punto crítico es de esta forma es
decir debemos encontrar las x para lo
cual esto se anula sin embargo era la
menos 2x cuadrada nunca nunca es 0
verdad entonces esto de aquí por ejemplo
cuando es esto el exponente es muy
negativo digamos
si se aproxima a cero pero nunca es cero
ok entonces esto nunca es cero así que
lo único que nos queda ver es cuando
será cierto que 1 menos 4 x cuadrada es
igual a 0 y esto es muy fácil porque
sumamos 4x cuadrada de ambos lados y nos
queda que uno es 4x cuadrada dividimos
ambos lados entre 4 y nos queda un
cuarto es igual a x cuadrada y si
sacamos raíz cuadrada obtenemos que
bueno tenemos que sacar tanto la raíz
positiva como la negativa verdad ambos
son soluciones de esta ecuación y nos
queda que es más o menos un medio que es
la raíz cuadrada de un cuarto muy bien
entonces uno puede realmente verificar
que la derivada en un medio es cero y
que la derivada en menos un medio
también es cero ambos son valores
críticos de nuestra función y son los
únicos entonces los valores críticos
valores
críticos los valores críticos son dos y
son un medio y menos un medio